The following trailer is rated S for spoilers.
From the director who exploded onto the scene
then went out like a hot fart
Comes what might be M. Night Shyamalan's greatest... surprise... yet!
He's actually kinda good again.
I did not see this happening.
What? No?
Split
James McAvoy stars as man with 24 split personalities in the same body
but get ready to see about only 8 of them.
a kinda which kinda blend together.
I think i'm talking to Denis.
Still, he'll teach a masterclass and channeling a wide variety of creepy personalities, like:
Creepy child.
Someone's coming for you.
-Creepy Tim Gunn.
That one. I'm gonna hand-print it
with newspaper headlines.
And, creepy Mrs. Doubt fire
I think I'll put a pretty
flower in your hair.
As they do wonderfull job explaining how so many personalities can co-exist in his mind,
But ignore one big question!
How does he always have the right clothes nearby when he changes?
Does he keep grandma's sweater in every room, just in case?
No!
Watch McAvoy act circles around
the rest of the cast,
How? - I know.
Litteral circels, because this dumbass victim stand around, waiting to be eaten.
Or lock themselves in the lockers.
Or not run away when this happens.
Okay, and run, run.
Okay, and... go.
Run away, right now.
Run, you moron!
But, don't worry, fans of the old bad Shyamalan, because he'll still be guilty of his trademarks.
Like, vacant staring
Wooden acting.
-I'm proud of you., i think.
And the worst dialogue
the side of the Happening.
Jai, what health-conscious
fast food purveyor
did you originally solicit
to buy these chicken wings
you've so lovingly reheated
in a minor suicidal gesture?
Yep, there is the M. Night
we all know and hate.
So, prepare for dawn of the new Shyamalansans.
In a film that doesn't just
kick ass as a standalone movie.
And also works as.... Hold on,
if you dont want twist in a Split ruined,
you are gonna clear out for this part.
It's ok, i'll give you some time to click away while we watch the wind from Happening.
OK? Everyone gone who doesn't want the big twist spoiled?
Alright, here goes.
It's a secret sequel to Unbreakable.
How cool is that?
A movie 17  made by years old studio,
which most of the audience likely forgot about.
There is no way you saw that coming.
Now i can have wondering,
is it all connected?
Who else could show up in Shamala verse?
Could we get a whole the Shamala's ventures with the kid who see dead people?
Aang and Cypher Rage?
Nevermind, that will be terrible.
You are not out of dog house,
yet, Nightman.
Starring:
The ol M. Night cameo.
Personalities 9-23.
Mr. Plinkett's basement.
Beastmode activated, and
What it's like to be a girl on the internet.
Take off your skirt and
take off your shirt.
Just take it off. Can i kiss ya?
10 Cloverfield room.
I do have the ability to use Kevin's full name
and bring him forward.
This guy is not gonna be
much of a challenge to Bruce Willis.
He's got the same weakness
as Rumpelstiltskin.
Thanks for watching,
for even more Honest Trailers
including Rogue One a Star Wars story
and a bad M. Night Shyamalan
movies click the boxes above.